we are not working here from theory
where we really are theories are the
weakest part of what we say what we're
working from is the fact of an
experience which we need to make sense
of now let's most of these other
oriented experiences which are hard to
keep track of or makes sense of cannot
be commanded freely they're more in the
realm of you know you're travelling in a
foreign country and you contract the
terrific fever and you fall into a
vision and you have deep awareness and
realization about the nature of life
this is not an experience that can ever
be repeated or you're alone in a
wilderness and you confront a flying
object in the sky which seems to trigger
strange bursts of thought in yourself
this cannot be repeated and triggered on
command so only in the context of the
psychedelic experience and the willed
decision to act can you enter this arena
of repeatedly going to meet the
experience of the other and it is a very
very bizarre enterprise it is not that
if we do it enough times we will
understand it or become comfortable with
it because it is not in its nature to be
understood and it is not in its nature
to accommodate itself to us rather it's
that we've discovered another dimension
almost in the same way that Europeans
discovered another world only five
hundred years ago in 1992 we will
celebrate the 500th anniversary of
Columbus's two
governor of America now notice that when
Columbus set out from Spain there was a
large body of intelligent opinion which
believed that he was sailing over the
edge of the world literally that he was
sailing out of mind and instead what
what lay at the end of that voyage was
real-estate immense amounts of real
estate and we have come to terms with
that and in fact now inhabit what five
hundred years ago was not even on the
maps it was in the unconscious now it is
the center of the global economy in the
same way that these European navigators
began to have this intimation that the
world was a wrap-around that's what it
means to say that the world is round it
means you can get back to where you
started from by going away continuously
in the same way that the european
navigators discovered that the world was
a wrap-around i think we are on the
brink of discovering that you can start
in three-dimensional space and time move
off in a linguistic vehicle and find
your way back to the place you left from
this means that what we call
three-dimensional space and what we call
the imagination actually have a
contiguous and continuous transformation
from one into the other and this is big
news this entirely goes against our
Cartesian expectation that thoughts
inside world outside objects outside
perceptions inside and this is actually
nothing more this inside outside thing
than an artifact of European languages
and yet we take it to be
you know how God made the world
basically because we are so embedded in
our language that we cannot literally we
cannot cog NIH's reality without it we
cannot cognize reality without our
language but then in the psychedelic
state somehow this happens somehow
syntax is replaced by hyper syntax
linguistically moderated and modulated
perception is replaced by perception in
the raw not coded and sculpted and
sifted for culturally validated meaning
but rather just the full hit well this
is tremendously disorienting but it's
also tremendously liberating because
that's the full deck that's when you
have full command of the options
available within the matrix if you play
the cultural game it's like playing only
with clubs or something or playing only
with the red marked cards you have to
play with a full deck and that includes
this pre-linguistic surround in which we
are embedded now why is it so
emotionally charged for us in other
words why can the shamans go into this
dimension and heal or or divine see into
the future or in a sense see into the
past by discovering who stole whose cow
or who's sleeping with who or all these
things that shamans are concerned with
what is this ground of being that we
discover by dissolving the cultural
machinery of cognition well I think
what it is is simply a reality
unpackaged for a historical epoch in
other words reality unn compromised by
the need to be culturally efficacious
and useful and this is precisely what we
need to throw light on our culture
crisis because the models that we have
used to sanction information that is
culturally useful have given us
information which is toxic I mean we
have actually created a toxic
relationship between ourselves and
nature we have pursued avenues of
questioning the feedback from which have
given us an overpopulated polluted
ideology obsessed unresponsive planet
[Music]